Уявіть майбутнє, в якому все ваше мило зроблене з забрудненого повітря.
Або горілка з викидів. Або навіть ваша обручка - жартую, навіщо ті заручини?
Насправді це майбутнє не таке вже й захмарне.
Щоб досягти кліматичних цілей, поставлених у Парижі, світ має позбутися 1 мільярду тонн CO2 до 2025 року.
Це означає, що нам треба було б пришвидшитися, десь так... учора.
Такі компанії, як німецька Covestro, перетворюють CO2 на матеріали, які входять майже до всього:
матраци, медичне обладнання, шкарпетки, кросівки, автокрісла, чохли для телефонів, утеплювачі, підлога.
Я могла би продовжувати, але не буду.
Звучить добре, але чи справді це вплине на кількість вуглецю? І як взагалі виглядає перероблений вуглець?
У 1970-их роках нафтові корпорації фактично використовували виловлені викиди
для закачування CO2 в нафтові свердловини, щоб підвищити видобуток нафти.
Ми також можемо конвертувати це забруднення і зберігати його глибоко в землі.
Але чому б не переробляти CO2 у щось інше?
Ця технологія називається Вуглецеве вловлювання й утилізація (Carbon Capture and Utilization).
Тож для чого ми можемо використовувати перероблений вуглець?
Вуглець практично у всьому.
Це Сьюзен Фенсі. Вона менеджерка програми Глобальна ініціатива CO2 Мічиганського університету.
Експертка у захваті від технології вуглецевого вловлювання.
У наші дні, якщо я йду в магазин одягу, більшість одягу сьогодні виготовляють із синтетичних тканин,
і весь цей одяг виготовляють із викопного палива.
Візьміть до прикладу ці матраци. Більшість з них зроблені пінополіуретану.
Матраци виглядають простими…
Це Крістоф Ґюртлер. Він розробляє продукти в Covestro, і він знає про піну більше, ніж будь-хто, кого ви знаєте.
Отже, у вас є величезний блок пінополіуретану, приблизно 10-20 кг.
Ми беремо CO2 і просто замінюємо частину викопного палива, необхідного для створення цих матраців.
Цей процес замінює до 20% викопного палива переробленим вуглекислим газом.
Щороку в ЄС викидають понад 30 мільйонів матраців.
Якби всіх їх скласти один на одного, стос був би у 678 разів вищий за Еверест.
Тим часом Крістоф випереджає моє питання.
Питання журналістів завжди "один такий метод не допоможе вам врятувати світ".
Я кажу, що так, ви абсолютно праві, але це не наш намір.
Адже виготовлення таких продуктів водночас може вимагати надмірного споживання енергії.
Перетворення CO2 в полімери та паливо, як правило, є більш енергоємним, ніж виробництво інших складових.
Ми можемо робити це, тільки якщо використовуємо зелену енергетику.
Ми запитали Ґерґе Деерберґа, дуже розсудливого інженера-хіміка,
про енергоефективність виробництва продуктів і матеріалів із вторинного СО2.
Це, на мою думку, головне слабке місце. У нас не вистачає зеленої енергії
для виробництва зелених хімікатів, а також виробництва зеленої сталі тощо.
Тож навряд чи ми врятуємо планету, якщо купуватимемо вуглецево-нейтральні шкарпетки.
Кількість вуглекислого газу, яка може надходити в хімічні речовини, пластмаси та волокна,
буде надто малою, щоб суттєво зменшити викиди у всьому світі.
Це від 40 до 90 мільйонів метричних тонн на рік. До вашого відома, ми викидаємо 33 мільярди тонн на рік.
Тому нам потрібно замінити вуглець у масштабніших процесах.
І вгадайте, яка галузь є однією із найкращих кандидаток для цього?
Цемент.
Лише на цемент припадає 8% світових викидів вуглекислого газу.
З хімічних причин ви не можете виробляти цемент без викидів CO2.
Це одна галузь, яка повинна виробляти вуглець.
А це - Кріс Стерн. Він знає про цемент усе.
Цемент - це не найпривабливіший об'єкт. Але ми намагаємося його таким зробити.
Кріс заснував компанію, яка виробляє бетон з негативним вмістом вуглецю,
замінюючи цемент сталевим шлаком, побічним продуктом металургійної промисловості.
У Кріса дуже підприємницький дух.
Ну хтось же має це зробити, правильно? То чому не я?
Замість того, щоб намагатися декарбонізувати цемент, ми придумали процес заміни цементу.
Компанія Кріса отримує CO2 від промислових постачальників газу,
які збирають та очищають газ із промислових викидів.
Але насправді його компанія продає технологію.
Кріс працював зі вченими з Університету Макгілла, щоб розробити патент на процес під назвою CO2 затвердіння.
Згідно з процедурою, CO2 вводять в абсорбційну камеру, де газ
реагує зі сталевим шлаком і перетворюється на стабільні карбонати кальцію.
Тож скільки CO2 це насправді компенсує?
Ми уникаємо двох кілограмів викидів CO2, не використовуючи цемент,
і можемо закопувати до кілограма CO2 в цей бетонний блок.
Таким чином загальне змішане зменшення вуглецю становить приблизно 3 кілограми на 18-кілограмовий блок.
За допомогою цієї технології ми можемо позбутися мільйонів і мільйонів тонн вуглецю. Це неважко.
Сьогодні в усьому світі щороку використовують приблизно 230 мільйонів тонн CO2.
Але поки що у нас є змога виловити лише мізерні 40 мільйонів тонн на рік,
і 70% з них припадають на Північну Америку.
Якщо ми зможемо замінити більш-менш пристойну кількість цих викопних джерел
переробленим вуглецем, то ми зможемо зменшити вуглецевий слід на 50 відсотків.
Однак технологія вуглецевого вловлювання й утилізації ще на початкових стадіях.
Необхідно інвестувати набагато більше грошей у технології й інфраструктуру.
Скільки це коштуватиме?
Багато грошей.
Принаймні всі погоджуються, що потенціал у цьому є.
За оцінками консалтингу McKinsey & Company, ринок продуктів на основі вуглекислого газу
в 2030 році становитиме від 800 мільярдів до 1 трильйона доларів.
За умови, що компанії розпізнають бізнес-модель.
Я думаю, що ми ще насправді не знаємо, що буде комерціалізоване, що з  цього вийде.
Я маю на увазі, що саме буде працювати? Отже, ми говоримо про принаймні 20-річний термін.
Що приводить нас до більшого питання: чи віримо ми, що ринок самостійно подбає про проблему?
Абсолютно. 100 відсотків. Такі люди, як я, створюють компанії і вирішують проблему, чи не так?
Як інакше це відбудеться?
Часто люди кажуть, що якщо "ти робиш щось екологічно, то хто за це заплатить?"
За це доведеться заплатити споживачеві.
Ці нові продукти можуть продаватися, але, звичайно, вони будуть дорожчими.
І це прогалина, яку треба закрити державним регулюванням на ринках.
Ваш матрац може подорожчати, але це, ймовірно, і буде правильною ціною,
яку потрібно заплатити, щоб... ну, спати на матраці.
Ми не можемо визнати, що над нами нависла екзистенційна загроза,
а потім продовжувати жити так, як ми жили.
Можливо, найбільший вплив технології вуглецевого вловлювання й утилізації -
це заміна викопних газів. Але ми не можемо думати про це як про нескінченний кошик переробки.
Зрештою, ми повинні звернути увагу на весь життєвий цикл CO2 –
звідки він надходить, куди йде і куди потрапляє, коли термін служби продукту закінчується.